in the past few years there's been an
increasing range of cultural
manifestation with the seeming purpose
of replacing the masculine whether it's
the new Ghostbusters Doctor Who the slew
of Marvel heroes being replaced by
feminine versions of themselves certain
this list is getting longer of course
those who are doing this think they're
doing women a service by leveling the
field but there's strange irony is
running through these political chess
moves as instead of creating powerful
cultural images of the feminine you put
female bodies on masculine ideals and
the question begs to be answered are we
actually dismissing the masculine or are
we dismissing the feminine by doing this
or maybe it's both but when it comes to
replacing the masculine while preserving
the feminine the Disney movie Moana
appears as one of the most successful
giving this cultural movement an almost
mythical expression so we're going to
look at Moana and see how that plays out
in the movie and what the consequences
are
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
now in all my movie interpretations I
tell people to pay attention to the
opening sequence as usually the entire
movie reveals itself there and this is
no exception the beginning of the movie
is the beginning of this new feminine
world it's a creation myth the story of
how the world began and we're told in
the beginning there was only oh now
immediately we should be suspicious
because in the traditional Maori myth
like in so many other cultures the world
is made by the union of opposites heaven
and earth the great father and the great
mother
this traditional myth will that will
actually continue to be there in the
movie as a kind of ghost a kind of
invisible strangeness a feeling that
something isn't quite right and how
things develop but in this story in this
creation myth here in this movie there
is only the feminine part the earthly
part the ocean and out of this
primordial chaos emerges the mother
Island to feety which is an image of the
let's call er the new-agey mother earth
who by her heart has the power to create
life we're told that soon some began to
covet the heart and were shown a sea
serpent and then all the characters who
want to steal the heart in the actual
movie the crab the Pirates and then
finally Maui notice first of all that
all these characters are masculine but
notice mostly that Maui lifts off into
the sky as an eagle to steal the heart
were finally shown the masculine
counterpart to the mother earth
character we are shown the heavens and
this image of the masculine is not there
to act as a complement to unite with
earth and create life but is there to
steal the heart of the earth and unleash
a progressive destruction of all things
one of the things that Maui is known for
especially is that he is the one who
pulled out the islands from the sea with
my tea hook the hook is an image of
technology in its most basic sense it is
the tool by which humans can act upon
modify and rein in the chaotic world the
fishhook is particularly this because it
goes down into chaos into the water and
catches that which is useful that which
can be eaten or integrated by human
society the hook is a tool of logos just
think of the fishing imagery used by
Christ so the idea of pulling dry land
out of the sea is this ultimate capacity
to pull something out of chaos and make
it useful but in the specifics of these
islands it also makes them a kind of
vertical height on the horizontal
backdrop of the waters pulling an island
out of the water is pulling it towards
heaven so we find ourselves in a village
and one of the strange ghostly feelings
I mentioned appears immediately at the
beginning because for some reason Moana
will be the next chief all the Chiefs
before her were men but without
explanation were meant to simply accept
that this young girl will replace her
father as the chief he takes her to the
highest place on the hill and shows her
a column made by a series of stones each
place by the proceeding Chiefs and he
tells her that as the next chief she
will one day place her stone on the
pillar but the malays continues because
this rather masculine vertical column is
actually a continuation of what Maui did
in the beginning that is by adding a
stone on the pillar stone one is pulling
the island even higher up towards
heavens making the island higher you
will raise this whole island higher of
course Moana in this movie is the chosen
one chosen to take the heart of taffy t
get Maui so
now we can replace the heart on this
journey Moana has a series of allies her
mother her grandmother the ocean itself
all these feminine type characters and
then she has a series of all-male
obstacles her father who doesn't want
her to go the Pirates and the crab who
want to steal the heart and then finally
there is Maui who is supposed to help
her though he is actually the cause of
this whole apocalyptic situation in the
first place there is of course one major
feminine obstacle take ah the fire demon
but as we discover in the final reveal
of the movie tika is actually only a
victim of Maui so let's look at Maui for
a second now he is supposed to help her
but he doesn't in fact help her at all
nope no now he actually doesn't do
anything Moana is the one who takes the
heart back from the Pirates she is the
one who gets Maui's cook from the crab
and then she is the one who ends up
putting the heart back into defeat II
now he does not really help her at best
when Moana is figuring out the Hart
dilemma at the end
Maui acts as a distraction but even
there we finally discover that all the
damage he is doing to the fire demon
tikka is actually just continuing the
violence and abuse that he operated on
defeat he by stealing her heart like I
said take ah appears as Maui's victim
there is a concise image of the dynamic
between Moana and Maui in the movie an
image of how the whole point of Maui in
this movie is that he has supplanted
Milana and it appears immediately when
they meet
first off maui goes into a song which
marks the quote unquote patriarchy
because now he insists on saying you're
welcome
for all the civilizing he's done
[Music]
oblivious to the fact that no one is
saying thank you thank you that he is in
fact the cause of the ecological
disaster upon them but then when maui
shuts Moana in a cave she escapes by
climbing up a statue of Maui and then
toppling the statue in order to escape
through a - obviously feminine-looking
opening the toppling of Maui and the
civilizing spirit he represents is the
actual led motive of the entire movie
the most aggressive version of the male
bashing in this movie is in mallanna's
animal sidekick the brainless [ __ ] the
rooster is an age-old image of the
masculine he is traditionally placed on
the summit of houses in the guise of a
weather vane but the rooster has also
been seen as the delusional masculine
the prideful and boastful one who thinks
that he is the one whose call summons
the Sun and so by making a rooster the
most brainless thing imaginable opens up
all kinds of possibilities of jabbing
below the belt don't believe me boat
snack Maui did you just choke that
chicken now as I said there are some
strange ghosts in the movies
strange reminders of what the story
should have been for example there is a
very powerful object in the movie when
Mona's grandmother is dying
she gives Moana a locket into which to
keep the heart of taffy tea the locket
is composed of two waves a dark and a
white one against each
and is an obvious reference to the
yin-yang symbol by putting the heart
which is also the seed the point at the
center of the spiral into the locket
this is an image of how the seed of life
the root of life appears as the joining
of heaven and earth masculine and
feminine and so it would only have been
fitting that Maui returned the heart of
to Fiji as it was prophesized at the
beginning you see the idea of placing
the seed in the center of the mother so
that she can bring forth life is well
just basic birds and bees but this is
not what this movie is about it is about
the civilizing masculine who destroys
life and brings about ecological
disaster and so when Moana returns home
and becomes the chief of a tribe instead
of taking a stone and increasing the
pillar pulling the island further up
into heaven she takes the shell which is
the ocean gave her which comes from the
bottom of the world the shell which is
shown overtly pink and stylized to look
rather well let's say to look feminine
and places it on top of the pillar by so
doing stopping the pillar from getting
any higher stopping the masculine line
of Chiefs for good and because it is
impossible to add anything on the pillar
now it is at the same time announcing a
kind of end a kind of transition where
her people will once again take to the
ocean by changing the traditional terms
of a fairy tale or myth Moana
contributes to the growing confusion
between the very primordial masculine
and feminine categories categories which
have not only regulated societies from
time immemorial but also ensure the very
existence of the human race mana
proposes a world in which the mother the
hero the wise one
the chief or all roles played by women
and the masculine once toppled will
receive whatever power he has only by
the gracious acquiescing of the Great
Mother you know it it'd be rude to
refuse a gift from a goddess thank you
your kind gesture is deeply appreciated
so I hope you enjoyed my analysis of
Moana you probably notice that there's a
lot more complexity in the video more
video layering you know more timing with
the between the text and the video of
the movie and that's really to celebrate
that I'm almost reached $500 from my
patrons on my patreon account at 500 I'd
promised that I would I would ramp up
the level of the videos that I'm doing
and so it's very excited to seeing all
of you who were supporting me who were
following me writing comments and so if
you if you like what I'm doing please
consider giving a little bit a month so
that we can make these even better and
so that I can be more involved in these
talks the more I'm the more I'm seeing
the results the more I'm excited to do
this even more than carving and so next
week I'm going to be in Vancouver with
Doran peterson and brett weinstein for
students for liberty event and so that's
really a whole exciting new door that's
opening up and so let's keep going